aufenthalt im all verlängert das leben
es gibt neue erkenntnisse zur auswirkung
des weltalls auf den menschen welche
dass er vater jetzt bei 552 kommt die
idee der nasa war wirklich ziemlich
genial wie bekomme ich möglichst
zuverlässig heraus wie sich das leben im
all auf den menschen aufhört ganz
einfach mit villingen
die nasa hat erste ergebnisse dieses
frühlings experiment veröffentlicht die
zwillinge scott und mark kelly stellten
dafür die perfekten probanten darf
während mark kelly auf der erde verwalte
ging scott kelly ein jahr lang seine
arbeit auf der internationalen
raumstation iss nach anhand der beiden
wollten direkt nach kopf rückkehr zur
erde er für analysen durchgeführt werden
nach der landung schien aber erstmals
alles aus der bahn zu beraten am
mittwoch den zweiten märz landeten der
isaf ab sofort kelly und seine kollegen
sergej volkov und michail kornjenko
sicher auf der erde
ein paar monate später klagte über
starke gesundheitliche probleme seine
haut brennen die füße seien bunt und die
beine während zeitweise starke die
selbst wäre nach der erfolgreichen
landung am liebsten direkt in ein
krankenhaus gegangen
beim zustand überraschte viele denn in
den 340 tagen die er im alfa brachte
zeigte er sich immer nur gut gelaunt und
körperlich ging es ihm scheinbar gut
zitat das liegt aber daran dass ich ein
richtig guter schauspieler bin ich finde
ich sollte für einen oscar nominiert
werden so kelly war
jetzt geht es ihm aber wieder soweit gut
und er konnte auch jede menge zur studie
beitragen dass im weltraum die muskeln
kaum beansprucht werden und man somit
tagtäglich am muskelaufbau arbeiten muss
um den rasch voranschreitenden abbau
entgegenzuwirken ist klar
wie sieht es aber seitens der gene aus
hat das weltall einfluss darauf kann
sich unser erbgut im all verändern
nachdem scott kelly nach seiner ankunft
so schlecht ging könnte mehr davon
ausgehend dafür wenn es etwas bewirkt
dass nicht unbedingt positiv sein wird
die experten wurden aber ein
zitat das ist genau das gegenteil von
dem was wir erwartet haben so fügen
bailey von der colorado state university
die aus den dna sequenzen bekannten kilo
meere seien bei scott kelly etwas länger
als die seines zwillingsbruders gewesen
und damit sind wir wieder am anfang des
videos
elizabeth blackburn von der universität
von kalifornien in san francisco zufolge
gebe es nämlich statistisch gesehen
einen zusammenhang zwischen kilo mehr
länge und alter logisch geschlussfolgert
heißt dass sie länger die telomere desto
länger die lebenserwartung stieg scott
kelly also jetzt ein längeres leben
bevor
nein leider nicht die telomere hätten
sich auf der erde schnell wieder zur
norm zurück gebildet
aber was wäre gewesen wenn es kommt
immer im all geblieben wäre
er legt nahe dass er dann wirklich
länger leben könnte auf jeden fall
interessante erkenntnisse wenn euch
dieses video gefallen hat freue ich mich
über ein abo dafür einfach hier klicken
und dann den klick auf die glocke nicht
vergessen dann werdet ihr auch immer
hier oben irgendwo unter der glocke
informiert oder kriegt eine million nach
eurem einstellung macht blockiert würde
passieren wenn man herausfinden würde
dass das all wirklich lebensverlängernd
wirken würde also ich bin auf eure
kommentare gespannt und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt plan